what is the difference between
mathematics and physics well uh
that's a difficult question because in
many ways math and physics
are unified in many ways so to
distinguish them is not an easy task
i would say that perhaps the goals are
of math and physics are different
math does not care to describe reality
physics does that's the major difference
but a lot of the
thoughts processes and so on which goes
to understanding the nature and reality
are the same things that mathematicians
do so in many ways they are similar
mathematicians care about deductive
reasoning
and physicists or physics in general we
care less about that
we care more about interconnection of
ideas
about how ideas support each other or if
there's a puzzle con
discord between ideas that's more
interesting for us
and part of the reason is that we have
learned in physics that the ideas are
not sequential
and if we think that there's one idea
which is more important and we start
with there and go to the next idea
and next one and deduce things from that
like mathematicians do
we have learned that the like the third
or fourth thing we deduce from that
principle turns out later on to be the
actual principle
and from a different perspective
starting from there leads to new ideas
which the original one didn't lead to
and that's the beginning of a new
revolution in science
so this kind of thing we have seen again
and again in the history of science we
have learned
to not like deductive reasoning because
that gives us a bad
starting point to think that we actually
have the original thought process
should be viewed as the primary thought
and all these are deductions
like the way mathematicians sometimes
does so in physics we have learned to be
skeptical of that way of thinking we
have to be a bit open to the possibility
that what we thought is a deduction
of a hypothesis actually the reason
that's true is is the opposite and so
we reverse the order and so this this
switching back and forth between ideas
makes us more fluid about a
deductive fashion of course it sometimes
gives a wrong impression like physicists
don't care about rigor they just
you know they just say random things you
know they are willing to to say things
that are not backed by you know
the logical reasoning that's not true at
all so
despite despite this fluidity in saying
which one is a primary thought
we are very careful about trying to
understand what we have really
understood
in terms of relationship between ideas
so that's
that's the that's an important
ingredient and in fact
solid math being behind physics is i
think
uh one of the attractive features of a
of a physical law so we look for
beautiful math underpinning
you